welcome to this video playing Hagen from
Spain let's see maybe ash could do
something a la let's let's do let's do
this one from Bosque don't play that
frequently but why not for a change yeah
this looks very much like a French
defence mmm may I don't really want to
help him to get the night back into play
you should basics now loses a piece so
not a good idea with of queenie queenie
format the engine okay one Queen g4 now
probably Wilco bishop evade this is the
way this is so normally played nope okay
I'll take this this chance and try to
open up the kingside quickly night h3 is
also a good idea night 8 32 g 5
okay i'm risking this possible capture
doesn't do it okay but then he needs to
handle the noise i'm very annoying piece
on g5
it always at xf7 so it's quite difficult
to ignore it okay I don't don't really
think it helps to delay castles any any
longer let's see maybe g3 you I need to
my 23 mm-hmm what I'm getting at and I'd
like to have a light on F for putting
pressure Queen g3 Queen geez over here
this is a good move it allows Knight f3
yes and it also has the c6 idea if the
moment is right now 96 I take and play
Bishop g5
yeah II 5e six this is a very important
motif hmm yeah this is a movie even here
but um I'd like to so many attractive
moves maybe maybe prepared 96 is still
not great just strategically speaking
with Bishop g5 now yeah yes the
notoriously problematic bishop against
the night
not quite sure I mean if it takes I'll
take with the rook anyway I'm not going
to open in the C file I'd like to what
i'm doing a summary routing the be sure
the Knight to f4
don't weant rate I will probably take
with the pawn and night f4 just a very
view just a very one-sided position
the waveform with this f3 ng for opening
up
rakta form
now the problem is I mean you can never
allowed trade rooks it just leads to
this
aha yeah I'm it's time that I relaxed
too much
no before I can taking takes rook c4
check this is Sam this is not ideal at
all
yeah well I'm seeing a line that still
is okay but it's not ideal our wait wait
wait wait wait it's it's much easier if
he takes I can take with the pawn Roxy
tours just just isn't much of a problem
this is strong brooksie wanna next move
yeah okay the only question is do I
actually win it do I actually win then
it's probably not so great to exchange I
have a better idea I think rook be one
attending night you want and then the
rook must retreat I'd like to have the
rook the rooks on yeah this is stronger
yeah yeah this was important i think
it's not gay him sexy porn i'll take it
i mean and now i know i can actually
play um no i can actually play a
look-see one takes takes King be five
hmm
hmm
yeah this wasn't the most precise way to
play very very sure yeah especially the
time yeah he's still basically playing
without this Bishop on f7 so why should
be should be good but still I probably
had much better much better ways to play
the only as a check a check
andy sixx is gone 20 seconds is the
problem not the position really
is spending some time time is a good
sign chats little tricks
check now the pawn should win
black forfeits on time well yeah it
would have could have been really
heartbreaking if I would have lost that
due to my bed time management I mean
it's always your fault but um this was
such a such a nice position all along
okay well he took let's review that yeah
rook yeah this is right rather typical
of the computer it once play whoopsie
one and I'm not I'm not clear I'm not
sure if white wins this the compass on
+1 but how do you actually break through
it's not so easy it it's totally passive
I know but if whatever place be four
black plays a four if you play it for
you plus B form the King does not enter
you can play a 3g for I just take it
twice how do you win it's very tricky
very tricky I'm not sure if white is
winning it looks overwhelming because of
this this piece on g7 I'll f7 but term
how do you win I think this is much
stronger and well this is a bit of a
panic move but if he play some something
something slow i played this 91 and push
the push truck back pretty good idea and
here I I just didn't play precisely he
could have taken yet King be five this
is what irritated me also the way to go
is probably play like that I now be
three there's something similar happened
in the game but I didn't he always could
take time for here I think I'm
again okay it's so just just too much
all right well if this was some tens at
the end thanks for watching